[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show this morning
an inspiration to the end tributes to
the cancer campaigner dame deborah james
who has died at the age of 40. we'll be
looking back at her life and asking how
you can spot signs of bowel cancer early
on
also on today's show with the prime
minister calling to dig deep to prepare
for a dangerous decade following
russia's invasion of ukraine is enough
being done and spent on defence
capability in the uk
we'll ask the defense secretary ben
wallace and we'll also talk to uh
labour's lisa mandy coming up it's
wednesday the 29th of june
[Music]
take risks
love deeply
have no regrets
dame deborah james family revealed the
cancer campaign as final words after her
death at the age of 40.
missile strike ukraine's president
releases a video showing the moment a
shopping center is hit
proof he says of russia targeting
civilians
[Music]
i'm live outside the shopping center in
kremenchuk where the recovery operation
is still underway
i'm live in madrid where boris johnson
will be urging allies to spend more on
defence and finland and sweden look
poised to join the nato alliance
i'm the president take me to the capitol
the bombshell testimony from a former
white house age around president trump's
actions on the day of the capitol riots
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
socialite to sex trafficker elaine
maxwell is sentenced to 20 years in
prison with this message to her victims
i hope my harsh incarceration brings you
closure
skelone must die in prison
because i've been in hull and back
for the last 17 years
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world
taking it to the supreme court nicola
sturgeon proposes a date next year for a
new scottish independence referendum
we'll speak to the first minister just
after eight o'clock
and america regulating a woman's body
more than it regulates guns or
you can't expect decency from those who
never had it in the first place a
fascinating debate to bring you on the
u.s abortion ruling at half past seven
[Music]
morning everybody she was an inspiration
to the end who single-handedly raised
millions of pounds for cancer research
the campaigner dame deborah james has
died at the age of just 40.
in a statement on her instagram page her
family shared dame deborah's final
thought she said
find a life worth enjoying take risks
love deeply have no regrets and always
always have rebellious hope
and finally check your poo it could just
save your life adele robinson has more
[Music]
deborah james won the hearts of the
country dancing through her cancer
treatment with humor and candor even in
her final days she raised millions for
cancer charities
the consultant who cared for her called
her achievements unparalleled
i'll remember as somebody who gave
incredible hope to many many people in
this country i can't go
out i'm sick
deborah james used her social media
platform bowel babe to break the taboos
of cancer her podcast you me in the big
c propelled the deputy head teacher to
fame her final episode was recorded
after she'd begun end of life care
i feel like i've been you know
playing with the devil and i think
you know we think oh no it's caught up
with me now
um
and i've i haven't really got my head
around this
her podcast producer mike holt spoke of
his love for deborah my phone will ring
any time of the day when i look down i
see it's deborah i'll think wow what's
this going to be next you know what's
going to what's the next idea devs
and
i'll miss her
it was obviously never my intention to
kind of die before it's released
even in her last few weeks she didn't
stop raising over 1 million pounds
through the launch and sale of her
fashion line basically from now on
[Music]
deborah announced her second book one
she won't now see published and
celebrated what she described as perfect
moments with her family
debra often dressed up to spread the
word for people to get checked for bowel
cancer that remains her overriding
message
deborah james didn't waste a moment of
her 40 years her relentless campaigning
will undoubtedly save the lives of
others
awarded a dame hood in her final weeks
a show of appreciation from a nation who
loved her
i suppose
that's it from me i can't believe it
that that is it for me
enjoy life because it is so precious
it's
all i want right now is more time and
more life
and
i would also check your p
adele robinson sky news
you can go to
her fundraising page if you'd like to um
get involved in raising uh money
um to try to help others defeat cancer
bowel babe fund for cancer research uk
uh presently standing at just less than
seven million pounds
and we'll have more tributes to dame
deborah later in the programme as well
as ways to spot bowel cancer
other news we've been talking about
ukraine with the uh or we will certainly
be talking to him about it the defense
secretary just looking for him at the
moment i'm sure he's around somewhere uh
before that let's bring in the uh
international affairs editor here at sky
dominic whitehorn he's in madrid and
sally lockwood who is standing by in
ukraine uh for us um sally i wonder if
we could go to you uh first we were
chatting to you yesterday you just
arrived
after the attack on this shopping center
what's it looking like there this
morning good morning
morning to uk yeah it became clear very
soon after arriving yesterday they
weren't going to find any more uh
survivors uh in this burnt out wreckage
uh that i'll give you a look at behind
me and certainly that has been confirmed
now by uh authorities that they are no
longer looking for survivors this is a
recovery operation uh 18 people have
been confirmed
to have died so far in in this attack
but there are still many many missing
some have been found in hospital there
were 40 people reported missing
initially some of those have been found
in hospital but certainly more than half
remain missing so
it is feared that the
death toll will grow human remains have
been recovered from the site and and
relatives who are looking for their
loved ones that are giving their dna to
a local police station in the hope of uh
getting some news and some answers as to
what happened uh but away from this uh
very grim recovery operation now is also
a war crimes investigation there were
investigator investigators down here uh
yesterday a large number of them
and certainly as evidence has emerged to
show that there was a missile strike on
this shopping center something russia
denies and in his overnight
address president zielenski actually
released a cctv footage himself very
dramatic images to show a missile uh
hitting this shopping center in
kremenchuk this industrial town in the
heart of ukraine uh so certainly uh
prosecutors and investigators will be
pouring over this evidence now uh to try
and work out whether this was a
deliberate hit something that president
zielinski says
it was but
aside from whether they managed to prove
if russia intentionally targeted this
shopping center what it doesn't change
is the fact that attacks on civilian
areas like this continue uh to happen
and ukrainian people continue to feel
at risk countrywide here these missile
strikes
are across the country not just in the
eastern donbass region or on the capital
kiev as we saw
earlier in the week and one other thing
i should say to uk is that they're also
investigating the fact that during the
air raid siren here shortly before that
attack
people didn't evacuate the building and
certainly i think after four months of
war people have become a little bit more
relaxed here when it comes to these air
raid sirens which go off in every city
almost every day but certainly that mood
is changing civilians across the country
are feeling much more threatened okay um
thanks very much indeed sally uh
meantime dominic what's happening in
madrid today to update us
well okay we're looking at arguably the
most important nato summit since the end
of the cold war certainly going to be
ushering the most sweeping radical
changes to the alliance since the end of
the cold war they'll be unveiling the
strategic concept now that's the way
nato plans and prepares for
threats and it hasn't produced one of
those for at least a decade so it's a
complete update an overhaul of that and
particularly in the light of the russian
threat the principle behind uh the
operations they've been working under
for the last decade or so is a tripwire
principle the idea that you have small
numbers of forces um on russia's border
in those baltic nations and their very
presence would deter russia from
invading knowing that if they invaded
those uh countries and attacked those
forces the whole of nato would pile in
and defend them well those baltic
nations have felt pretty worried by what
russia has done in ukraine so they're
going to massively increase the number
of troops in the east of europe but also
increase the rapids uh response force
from forty thousand to three hundred
thousand all of that is going to cost a
lot of money and we're going to be
hearing from the prime minister urging
his allies to spend more money britain
spends two percent of its gdp at least
on defence he wants to see his allies
spending that or at least more than that
so i think you'll be able to ask the
defense secretary ben wallace when he
finds him
exactly how much money britain should be
spending because we're getting a sense
there's a bit of a difference of opinion
between him uh certainly rishi sunak and
the treasury and possibly the prime
minister as well pleased to say that mr
wallace is with us now so i must bid you
both for well thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot uh defense secretary
joining us live from madrid hello to
defense secretary thanks for joining us
heard there uh from dominick waghorn
just how important this meeting is of
nato today um just want to remind our
viewers what you said um the government
said as part of their manifesto pledge
this um to increase the defense budget
each year by 0.5 percent above inflation
will the government be abiding by that
pledge
well i think a number 10 spokesman said
yesterday that they thought that was
unlikely given the
significant changes to inflation
as defense secretary my most important
target is remaining above two percent if
not greater of gdp which is the main
nato benchmark
and you know i think that's really
important that we continue to commit to
that if not greater and i think that's
what we're all here to discuss today in
uh madrid
two percent enough
well we're currently above two percent
uh at the
for this spending period that's the four
years of spending settlement i got from
the treasury we are on target to meet
our two percent uh and we're also uh on
target in other areas with our sort of
defense reforms the question is really
the next spending period the middle of
the decade and we were prepared to take
certain vulnerabilities uh on board in
the middle of the decade as we got rid
of some equipment and re-equipped with
new
i think the invasion of russia
you know into ukraine has changed that
and that's why i think the discussion is
so important for the sort of middle of
the decade funding so between now and my
converted spending review settlement
which ends in 2024 uh you know the here
and now we are rightly set we've got 24
billion pounds of record settlement the
question is what happens uh in the
middle of the decade and the future uh
if uh security and threat
becomes more of an issue
is 2.14 enough
i'm a defense secretary of the
department all departmental heads okay
will say they want more money
of course
in the here and now absolutely we have
enough money with enough money for next
year as well you know but what you
discover in in government in in
different departments is despite getting
the sums you've got to then spend them
properly and i've been determined to
make sure we are spending our money and
getting it out the door i think i think
what you'll see
across a whole range of government
departments is that despite settlement
it's often quite hard to you can't
immediately start building a hospital or
immediately start uh building roads and
that's no different for defense so look
for the here and now and for that
comprehensive spending review settlement
we are absolutely in the right place
post 2024 is really the discussions i
have with the chancellor and the prime
minister that i you know i i feel and i
said in a speech yesterday that you know
the security of this country is vital
that the work the men and women of our
armed forces do is incredibly important
we've all passed in their success in
helping with kovid with afghanistan
pitting and now leading from the front
on ukraine and i think that means that
britain wants to maintain this
leadership role post 2024 we're going to
have to see probably greater investment
we've we've spent 40 years nearly taking
a peace dividend
out of the end of the cold war sometimes
it's important to invest the prime
minister changed that direction of
travel which was
excellent news back in 2020 when he did
the
settlement gave me the record funding
that was a change of what had happened
for decades previously where people took
money out of defense every time
so we need to continue that that
direction of investment and if we do i
think we'll be able to give her an armed
forces that continues to help us lead
around the world okay you're telling my
viewers that for now we're in the right
place yesterday you said for too long
defense has lived on a diet of smoke and
mirrors hollowed out formations and
fantasy efficiency savings
yeah and that's why the prime minister
changed that direction with my
settlement 2020 uh the 24 billion pounds
a net increase in defense spending the
biggest since the cold war was exactly
to to answer that point so uh the it
actually says that in the full speech
okay if you read further into the speech
you'll see me say that you know that's
why the prime minister reversed decades
of direction of travel on defence the
key for me is defence secretary is to
make sure
that that you know government's appetite
for using its defense forces is matched
uh by its resources puts in place i i
can deliver an armed forces to keep
britain safe i can deliver an armed
forces to
be able to support our allies in the
world and stand up for our values but
but that will that obviously has to be
cut to our cloth and i think that's
really important that we always make
sure we do it in the past in history
prime ministers around you know have
often volunteered defense to do all
sorts of things and never then funded it
this prime minister has done that but
i'm just really keen that we recognize
that my settlement was done before
russia invaded ukraine russia is very
very dangerous and now on the world
stage the world is less secure than it
was two three years ago and is not
looking likely to change for the rest of
the decade i think that's a moment in
the middle of the decade to say we
should commit to increased funding
okay um i read in my weekend papers that
you wrote the prime minister asking for
a 20 hike in military spending was that
the case
no
how much would you like
well how long has a piece of string look
i i i could i can see opportunities all
over the world okay to to put the front
foot forward of the british forces again
that goes back to my earlier point about
the appetite of the government and how
much it wants to do
uh i i of course i want always enough to
meet the threat you know my my duty
uh to to you to the citizens of the uk
and and indeed to the country and our
allies is to have a
provide the government with a defense
force capable enough to defend against
the threats if the threat changes then
we should always consider uh that type
of investment to match it we do that in
many other departments around government
you know when when the nhs comes under
winter pressures for decades and decades
you know chancellors of the day have
stepped up and invested to meet that
response obviously
winter pressures in the army are
slightly different they they take place
over you know five six years but
nevertheless if the threat changes we
should always be open to increasing that
funding i've said that a number of
occasions before that's the right way to
do it because i'm i'm a threat-led
organization uh and for now between now
and 2084 we are in the right place the
question comes next what happens next
okay um as defense secretary um are you
completely content that as a country we
spend apparently proportionately less
than greece lithuania and estonia
well i think
look we are actually the second biggest
spender at the moment in europe we are
also i think the third biggest spender
in the world in defence so we spend a
lot of money if you talk about in cash
terms on defense obviously britain's gdp
or britain's cut britain's economy is
far bigger than some of those countries
you've just listed and therefore
if you spend even a baseline of defense
that comes close to one percent or two
percent uh that would be comparable to
us you'll discover that you know some of
those countries that higher percentage
reflects that their gdp their economy is
much smaller but overall
that we we have been the leader i'm
determined that we stay the leader in
the pack of that defense spend and
that's why i'm keen that we address the
sort of post 184 period
what's the point of um having a
manifesto pledge like uh 0.5 above
inflation spending on the defense budget
or saying that 300 000 new homes per
year are going to be built by the
mid-2020s or saying that 0.70 of gdp
will be spent on foreign aid or or that
we're going to get full fiber broadband
around the country by 2025 points of a
manifesto if you don't keep your
promises
well i
first of all i've been in politics long
enough kate you've seen every government
not fulfill 100 it's manifesto i i mean
what's the point then
what's the point of a manifesto if
you're not going to keep your property
with an offer to the public okay it's
saying what we are going to try and
deliver and deliver as a government it
is you can call it a promise we we we
promise to try and do these things but
some things it's more of a wish list
than a promise
right okay look do i think the manifesto
we have today would look the same
if it had been written post covert or
during covert i think it would have been
different you know i think covid was a
once in a hundred year once in a hundred
year plus type issue
and also we have an economic issue uh
you know
that that means we have to i mean a
responsible government would take
difficult decisions in light of the
facts changing i've just been saying to
uk about threat if threat changes we
should we should change our investments
in defense with it it is a perfectly
legitimate position to be in
and i think if the economic situation
has changed or all things are harder to
deliver than people thought and remember
to be fair uh it's not always as
straightforward there are always other
factors that affect us these things
sometimes take longer than we would have
liked but but you know it doesn't mean
to say it's not an aspiration you know
under this government the prime minister
did change absolutely changed the uh
uh defence investment he did something
that hadn't been done for decades and
you know if inflation hadn't
lifted off uh basically this year we
would be on track to meet our 0.5
percent
uh talk to me uh quickly um about
something that's also quite close to
your heart and that's uh scotland of
course we're hearing from nicola
sturgeon she said i've had enough of the
uk government and we're going to have a
referendum one way or another on
independence what would you say in
response to them
i went into the scottish politics
scottish parliament with nicolas
sturgeon literature has had enough of
westminster since 1999 when i went into
the scottish parliament with her the
problem is she's had enough of that but
she hasn't actually done her job of
delivering for the people of scotland
better healthcare better schools better
crime rates better uh education and all
the things that are really important
people scotland and instead she's
desperate i think now to have a have a
second referendum even though
all the promises were
a referendum is a once in a generation
well
there was a referendum it was all pretty
much handed over to the scottish
parliament to decide on everything from
its wording to its timing they had they
had the referendum uh they lost the
referendum uh and instead of them saying
okay hands up let's try and see if
there's a better way let's try and
better the people
of scotland's experience with public
services she's just banged on on the
same one-trick pony i think the problem
for nicola is time is running out
and you know i think she knows because
for all the sort of spin she put on
separation she knows that every day that
goes past every day further away from
her sort of referendum zeal or the
division that she stoked up the first
time round uh people are feeling that
belonging to the united kingdom is
probably a better option and the reason
they want to belong to the united
kingdom is if you look at covid the
scale of support to scotland could only
have been delivered by a greater
political union if you look at defense
you've got president putin in nuclear on
numerous occasions
and you know people in scotland realize
that we are greater together better
together as a nation okay you've
definitely had your three shredded week
this morning i can't get word in
edgeways just one final question before
i let you go pressure on the pm harriet
harman chair of the privileges committee
new chair of the privileges committee um
that will be looking into uh party gate
and the prime minister any concerns
about her appointment
no it's a matter for parliament uh you
know i i leave it to
the parliamentary uh arithmetic the the
people on the panel uh you know those
committees are deliberately set up so
that we have an opposition member
chairing that panel that's that's how
governments and standards should be held
to account we often do that on a range
of of different select committees but i
think the reality is uh she yes of
course she's the chair i'm sure all the
mps on there will look at the facts and
take their own decision
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us
thank you thank you thank you
uh time now for a look at this morning's
newspapers for you the financial times
leads with testimony from the january 6
insurrection committee hearing in
washington where it was alleged that
former president donald trump attempted
to join the armed mob storming the
capital even going so far as trying to
grab the steering wheel of his limousine
reporting on the sentencing in the
maxwell case the metro has the headline
delaying caged for 20 years the sun
carries tributes to the podcaster and
cancer awareness campaigner dame deborah
james whose death at the age of 40 was
announced last night
times reports on the metropolitan police
being placed in special measures after a
series of institutional failings
including its handling of the sarah
everard case
and the telegraph here is that boris
johnson is involved in an ongoing
disagreement with the defense secretary
and the head of the army who want to
increase military spending
still to come on the programme for you
this morning we'll speak to the british
medical association after gps at the bma
announced annual conference voted in
favor of industrial action over new
working contracts
just after eight we'll speak to the
shadow leveling up secretary lisa nandi
as labour calls on the government to get
a grip over rising costs pressures on
vital public services
and we'll speak to the first minister of
scotland nicola sturgeon to reply to
what we heard there from the defense
secretary after she set out her vision
for a second scottish independence
referendum
president donald trump new protesters
were armed but still encouraged them to
march on the capitol this the
extraordinary testimony from the
committee investigating the january 6
riots here's mark stone
cassidy hutchinson was at the heart of
the trump white house the principal aide
to donald trump's chief of staff the
witness will please stand and raise her
right hand the hearing was unscheduled
and the speculation over what she might
say huge the president
was
extremely angry
at
the attorney general's ap interview
and had thrown his lunch against the
wall
you can see a map of the first floor
of the west wing from the perspective of
an insider with a desk just yards from
the oval office she described a volatile
president in the days around the
storming of the u.s capitol
that morning on january the 6th 2021 mr
trump prepared to address his supporters
he was told some in the crowd were armed
but didn't care and wanted the magnetic
security screens to be removed
i overheard the president say something
to the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing mags away
let my people in they can march the
capital from here
pre-recorded and live testimony as the
committee seeks to prove that the former
president knew an armed mob was bent on
violence
and to prove that all this was the
culmination of his plan to overturn the
election result listen to this about the
moment the secret service deemed it too
dangerous for the president to go to the
capitol the president said something to
the effect of
i'm the effing president take me up to
the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle
up at the capitol they were calling for
the vice president to be hanged he had
defied trump and recognized joe biden as
president now we know the conversations
in the west wing i remember pat saying
something to the effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling
for the vice president to be effing hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
as ms hutchinson left the committee vice
chair republican liz cheney said the
case for prosecuting donald trump just
got much stronger mark stone sky news in
washington looking at some of today's
other headlines for you now
29 year old jordan mcsweeney has been
charged with the murder of 35 year old
zara alina in ilford in east london the
met police say he's also been charged
with attempted rape and robbery he'll
appear in court today mussolini was
fired with head injuries in the early
hours of sunday she died in hospital
later that morning
the metropolitan police has been placed
under special measures by the police
watchdog after it raised substantial and
persistent concerns about the force's
performance it means the met must now
develop an improvement plan to address
problems
travis barker has been taken to hospital
in california the blink 182 drummer was
pictured on a stretcher outside a
medical center in los angeles with his
wife kourtney kardashian by his side his
condition is not yet known
michael vorn has decided to step back
from his commentary work with the bbc
for the time being the former england
captain was dropped from coverage last
november after he was accused by several
players of making a racist comment
before a yorkshire game he has
categorically denied doing so the claims
came as part of the azim rafiq racism
scandal about prolonged abuse at the
club
a report from the climate change
committee says ministers plans for
tackling global warming won't deliver on
legal targets to cut emissions experts
are warning there's a shocking gap in
the government's efforts to ensure homes
are better insulated as energy bills
continue to soar
police in texas have charged two men
over the deaths of at least 51 suspected
migrants in an abandoned truck near san
antonio on monday officials said bodies
had been left strewn from a couple of
blocks after the truck's rear door had
opened a third suspect is still in
custody
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show nato leaders meeting
in madrid this morning in a show of
solidarity against russia boris johnson
is expected to tell leaders to dig deep
and invest more in defense over the next
decade earlier i spoke to our defense
secretary
all departmental heads okay will say
they want more money
of course
in the here and now absolutely we have
enough money of enough money for next
year as well you know but what you
discover in in government in in
different departments is despite getting
the sums you've got to then spend them
properly and i've been determined to
make sure we are spending our money and
getting it out the door i think i think
what you'll see
across a whole range of government
departments is that despite settlements
it's often quite hard to you can't
immediately start building a hospital or
immediately start uh building roads and
that's no different for defense so look
for the here and now and for that
comprehensive spending review settlement
we are absolutely in the right place
post 2024 is really the discussions i
have with the chancellor and the prime
minister uh that i you know i i feel and
i said in a speech yesterday that you
know the security of this country is
vital
uh tomorrow's here chancellor pm give me
more money indeed while the prime
minister is in madrid calling on other
countries to spend more on defence like
the uk does here is one of the prime
minister's key allies in cabinet using
the opportunity to say no prime minister
you need to spend more at home defense
got a very generous settlement in the
last spending review which was last year
and it's a three-year settlement so for
the next three years defense did better
than other government departments but of
course that was before the russian
invasion of ukraine at the end of
february and ben wallace is now saying
to the prime minister and chancellor
publicly from 2024 we need to spend a
lot more on defence and you need to get
the wheels in motion right now he
suggested that those discussions are
already underway and there is some
accusations in newspapers today that uh
downing street were taken by surprise by
um the pr by ben wallace's call for more
money uh yesterday and and the fact that
there was a leaked letter over the
weekend uh suggesting he wanted an extra
20 although uh in that interview of
course he denied that to you and said
you know
we're not putting figures on it but
certainly sounds like now public
posturing calling for for more money to
meet the current threat and he's
supported by liz trust the foreign
secretary who said yesterday that we
should be spending more as well uh
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock looking
forward to it uh now joe biden has said
he will continue to look for solutions
after the u.s supreme court overturned
the right to access an abortion in a
history-making decision that has divided
opinion across the country the court's
ruling last week overturned the
constitutional right to an abortion that
has existed for almost 50 years
following a legal case known as roe v
wade we thought we'd talk about it with
um scotty and dr schola and they are
with us now hello t-bo thanks for
joining us scotty to you first of all uh
you say abortion activists are raging
because they cannot murder babies you
cannot expect decency from those who
never had it in the first place perhaps
you'd like to expand on that for us
well ultimately kay this debate is not
necessarily about abortion rather it's
about states rights and our constitution
and our constitution is written that
unless it's specifically noted the power
goes back to the states and that is
literally in essence
what this ruling was and why the supreme
court said listen you can have an
abortion but that's going to be your
state's decision upon it as regarded in
our 10th amendment so yes in one way
this has been the rule of the law for 50
years that doesn't necessarily make it
right we do not have constitutional
rights in the united states to have an
abortion it's never mentioned in our
constitution and therefore giving the
power back to the state to make the
decision
is exactly what was right for the
supreme court to do this has necessarily
no changes the majority of states will
not see any changes with their abortion
law because of this and i just want to
remind people this is only because the
democrats were upset over a case in
mississippi if they would not have
appealed the case of mississippi roe
versus wade on the books would be
exactly as is but they decided to
challenge that case and the supreme
court took it up for the first time in
50 years and that is why we are are
where we are today
dr shola
i think that's an outright lie the
bottom line here is that roe v wade at
the decision by the supreme court and
pro-lifers by scotty is all about
subjugating women it's all about
taking the power from women to make
decisions over their bodies and over
their lives and please let's understand
this this has nothing to do with the
democrats the republicans have been
planning to do this for a long time
which is why trump put the kind of you
know the judges and conservatives
hardcore conservative judges in the
supreme court let us also understand
that this when we talk about
constitutional rights that the purpose
of the constitutional right is to
confirm
the human right that we have as human
beings abortion rights is health care
and if you're not ready to provide all
that is necessary for a woman to give
birth to a child if she's decided she
doesn't want that child whether it's due
to rape or for whatever other reason you
have no right none whatsoever to
determine for any woman what decisions
she should make over our own life now
what the supreme court did by passing
this on to the states and reversing roe
v wade is making women's rights over
their own bodies up for political debate
that is an insult that is disgusting and
i'm surprised at scotty as one woman to
another that that does not even cause
you any concern but i think that is
because
what you want is to be able to determine
for other women
like me
what we should what we should do with
our bodies whether we want to have
children or not and the point is i don't
care if you don't want to have an
abortion it should be none of your
business whether or not i want to have
an abortion or any other woman wants to
have an abortion what's going to be next
scotty you tell me are you going to are
we going to now stop i don't know
interracial marriages are you going to
penalize people or women who don't want
to have children at all come
this is nothing to celebrate it is
shameful and disgraceful and the fact
that you've come up here and decided to
say well actually
women shouldn't have this right there is
no absolute right it's not a
constitutional right it just tells me
again that all you're trying to do is
you're causing more division amongst us
women and that is part of the problem
the only person this benefits are men
well let's come back on that please if
you would please dr shola scotty your
response
well the fact that she says i don't know
what i said that was wrong because
everything i was said was based on fact
and the reality of it is only one
percent of abortions are actually
obtained because of right five percent
because of incest but the reality of it
is last year alone in 2020 930 000
abortions happened the majority of them
were second third or fourth abortions by
women and it's uh we don't have a right
to an abortion we don't have a right to
murder here in the united states you
have a right to live and in my beliefs
my religious beliefs as well as the
majority including the muslim faith the
buddhist faith majority of faith also
believed that life begins at conception
and here in the u.s unlike the uk the uk
you can have an abortion up to 26 weeks
in the u.s you could literally have an
abortion in some states all the way up
to the moment that the baby could have
been born the baby could have been
actually born alive and in many cases we
are seeing that that actually happened
sometimes in these horrible clinics that
babies that could have a chance at life
were murdered
and that is what we were trying to stop
with the system once again it's not
outlawing abortion it's just allowing
the states to make the decision for
themselves this is actually giving the
power to women to be able to live to
have a chance at life and that is what
we celebrate i'm sorry again that is a
lie it is taking what is it
what is a lie
it is decent civic what did i like
okay so it is taking power away from
women it's not giving power to women
particularly women powerful
i'm going to respond to you
it is taking power away from women it is
banning abortion that is absolutely
taking power from women and again you
keep referring to to this oh you know
the constitution does not specifically
say that you have got a right to push
well the constitution did not
specifically say that um you know black
americans have a right to vote it did
not specifically say that blacks or
white people can get married together it
does not specifically say all of these
things
ladies ladies ladies ladies thank you
scotty we'll come back to you in a
second dr scholar
the point is the constitution does not
give right to black people it does not
specifically say black people can vote
does not specifically say inter racial
marriages are right does not
specifically protect the rights of lgbt
community which is why many people many
marginalized communities have had to
fight for this right so you can't sit
there and say well because the
constitution doesn't say it because the
founding fathers could not think it
could not conform the thought that oh we
better write all these things down
because people are too dumb enough to
figure out actually liberty life means
everybody
that does not mean you get to say that
women should be denied the right to make
decisions over their own bodies so my
point to you is this this is taking the
power away from women black women
working class women who cannot afford
alternatives if you're so concerned
about the baby living why don't you talk
about universal health care universal
child care why don't you provide for
these babies once they're born but
you're not going to do that the
republican party is wrong you do that
because they're a bunch of hypocrites
you want the child to be born and then
you're going to reject a marginalized
child and then as hypocrites not even
lift a finger to feed the child shelter
the child or cloak the child so
i'm gonna let scotty come back there if
i may please but i just want to clarify
for you scotty actually it's 24 weeks of
pregnancy here in the uk but abortions
can be carried out after that time if
the mother's life is at risk go on
okay so here's the thing it's absolutely
pathetic and insulting to all of those
who have fought for historical changes
and in with the case of racial gender
all of those there has been amendments
passed so yes it is a part of our
constitution it was actually passed
through conduct that's why this is not a
federal right to an abortion it has
never passed there's not an amendment
therefore it goes back to the state if
people care so much about it pass it
through congress but even democrats who
hold the house and the senate refuse to
pass it through because they know that
is not what the people of the majority
of states do not want here in the united
states want to see a federal right to
abortion because you are limiting life
and that goes against our religious the
right to a religious stake in it it's
not about when of course it's about
it's not telling women that they can't
control their own bodies it's actually
given women a chance at life this has
nothing nothing to do with birth control
infertility treatments all of those
things all this gaslighting and
fear-mongering that people like show
with all due respect are trying to sell
us and trying to blur the issue because
when it comes down to it they just don't
like the fact that they cannot use
abortion as a source of birth control a
source of living instead of being
responsible where we now unlike the
1970s when birth control was not readily
available it is readily available in
every single community healthcare across
the united states people of all levels
of income can have responsible choices
like i said there is always a case in
the in the case of mothers obviously it
is a dog that is between a doctor and
the family to decide but people still
have the right to life that is
guaranteed by the constitution not the
right to end it and there's a big
difference between what the uk law is
and the u.s laws and in this case it
gives the states a chance to make the
decisions for their own you don't like
it go across the state line california
just to clarify actually abortion is
illegal in the uk except under certain
circumstances we'll be looking at that
uh with our former justice secretary um
a little bit later on in the programme
but dr scholler to scotty's point that
some women are using abortion as a form
of contraception and that cannot be
acceptable
right who are you to create what the
standards are my point is this when you
when you place on women this thinking
that well clearly you are wrong because
you're using it as contraception without
understanding the totality of the
circumstances you're using a blanket
mindset to subjugate women that right
there is wrong you do not know what the
totality of the circumstances of these
women are so i'm saying to you to back
the heck off and let's also understand
that using what whatever your beliefs
and values are to determine that another
woman does not come up to par to your
standard and beliefs it's absolutely
wrong because i don't get to decide for
you scotty and look i do agree i do not
understand why it's taking so long for
roe v wade to have been codified into
law it should have been what that wasn't
done by the republicans and the
democrats heaven knows but the bottom
line is that the one source by law by
presidents that women had
as a federal right and that's how they
saw it as has been taken away from them
bodily autonomy over a woman's body is
not up for political debate and that is
the point we should not be saying to
women
that you cannot think for yourself how
dare you have two three four abortions
when you do not know what your
circumstances are you're treating women
as lesser than less and you're coming up
with all of these so-called christian
values the christian values i i for all
as far as i'm aware the constitution
does not even refer to god the
constitution is not meant to be um to
merging to be run to the church and the
state but all republicans do is keep on
using their so-called
christian values to judge other people
and i'm a christian i'm a christian and
i'm saying to you that as far as i'm
concerned if abortion is a sin then it
is between the woman and god it's none
of your business
okay we must leave it there ladies um
thank you both very much indeed for
joining us on the programme this morning
we started with you scotty so we must
end with dr schola this morning thank
you both um and just to clarify um
abortion uh in the united kingdom two
doctors must approve uh the decision to
have an abortion um having and said that
the baby would pose a greater risk to
the physical or mental health of the
woman than a termination talking about
that in more detail as i said uh with
the former justice secretary dr um sir
uh robert buckland uh about half past
nine this morning meantime glenn maxwell
has been sentenced to 20 years in a u.s
prison for helping the deceased
financier jeffrey epstein abuse young
girls she was convicted in december of
recruiting and trafficking four teenage
girls for sexual abuse after listening
to the statements in court yesterday in
a surprise move elaine maxwell stood in
her prison clothes and issued a
statement to the victims
she said to you
all the victims that came to today
inside the court and outside i am sorry
for the pain you have experienced i hope
my sentence brings you closure peace and
finality i know my association with
epstein will follow and forever stay in
me it is the greatest regret of my life
that i ever met jeffrey epstein
some of the victims spoke outside court
it actually felt very powerful to
finally have a chance to speak and and
you know have my voice on the record
and say the things that i wanted to say
about how her crimes had impacted the
people impacted myself and the people
that that i know and care about yes
elaine must die in prison
because i've been in hell and back
for the last 17 years
joni is now a criminal lawyer and senior
trial counsel at joey jackson law and
that's bernarda villalona hello to you
thank you for joining us on the program
what did you make of the sentencing
i would tell you this that gelane
maxwell in court it was a courtroom
reckoning what took place with this
sentencing and her past trial one that
jeffrey epstein never had this sent a
loud message to predators all out there
that it doesn't matter how much money
you have doesn't matter where you come
from you are not above the law today
these victims got justice today those
victims got to voice their selves to the
judge who believed them listen to them
and exercise a just sentence of 20 years
for gelane maxwell now she'll probably
die in jail
just how important was it to have the
victims there
it was very emotional i can tell you i
actually sat through the victims talking
and giving how they felt
how they are affected by elaine maxwell
i mean they were in tears you heard some
of these victims says that they tried to
kill themselves
because of what they went through that
they suffered through depression that
they suffered through alcoholism that
one victim even said to elaine maxwell
look i met elaine maxwell just for you
to feed me to jeffrey epstein it was
horrifying i mean you got goosebumps
listening to these victims and what
they've been through these last couple
of years for over 20 years since having
met gallane maxwell
and will other high profile people
associated with the pair now be further
investigated do you think
i don't think that there's going to be
any further prosecutions i think if
there was going to be further
prosecution of other people that it
would have happened already elaine
maxwell she holds a lot of information
and she did not provide that information
to the department of justice or the u.s
attorney's office i think if she wanted
to provide that information to try to
help herself in the sense of a better
sense and she would have done that
already and especially with the passage
of time you got to think with statue of
limitations after a while you can't
prosecute certain individuals because of
the passage of time
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning thank you